en este vídeo hablaremos de uno de los
principios más importantes del cálculo y
que usaremos cada vez que tratemos de
encontrar derivadas medianamente
complejas nos referimos a la regla de la
cadena y al principio nos puede parecer
un poco complejo pero conforme veamos
más ejemplos nos daremos cuenta de que
no es tan complejo como pensábamos
digamos que tenemos la función hdx y es
igual a seno de x al cuadrado que
también podemos escribir como seno
cuadrado de x pero es más claro
expresarlo de la primera forma queremos
saber a que es igual h prima de x que
también podemos expresar como la
derivada de h con respecto a x para
calcular esto vamos a usar la regla de
la cadena siempre vamos a usar la regla
de la cadena cuando nos encontremos con
composiciones de funciones más adelante
entenderemos por qué se llaman sí ahora
imaginemos que queremos encontrar la
derivada con respecto a x d es decir
aplicamos el operador derivada de x
cuadrada a que es igual pues es igual a
2x lo que hemos visto muchísimas veces
ya que es igual la derivada con respecto
aa
de a cuadrada pues es el mismo resultado
solo reemplazamos la equis con la a esto
es igual a 2a ahora haremos algo que
puede parecer extraño vamos a calcular
la derivada con respecto a seno de x de
seno de x al cuadrado bueno pues hacemos
lo mismo que hicimos acá arriba con las
equis y las as pero ahora lo
reemplazamos con seno de x esto es igual
a dos veces la cosa con respecto a la
cual estamos derivando acá fue con
respecto a x acá fue con respecto aa y
aquí es con respecto a seno de x es
decir que es igual a 2 por seno de x la
regla de la cadena nos dice que esta
derivada va a ser igual a la derivada de
esta función externa al cuadrado con
respecto al seno de x es igual a 2 por
seno de x podemos verlo como la derivada
de la función externa con respecto a la
función interna tratamos a seno de x
como si fuera una equis y eso sería 2x
esto lo multiplicamos por la derivada de
seno de x que resaltamos en otro color
con respecto a x vamos a escribirla por
acá
no es tan difícil la derivada con
respecto a x dc de x es cosa de x esto
lo multiplicamos por coseno tx así
acabamos de aplicar la regla de la
cadena es la derivada de la función
externa con respecto a la función
interna que en el ejemplo vimos que es
la derivada de seno de x al cuadrado con
respecto a seno de x y esto lo
multiplicamos por la derivada de la
función interna con respecto a x que en
este caso es la derivada de seno de x
con respecto a x vamos a anotarlo para
que quede más claro
esta es la derivada de seno de x al
cuadrado con respecto a seno de x y esto
lo vamos a multiplicar por la derivada
de seno de x con respecto a x aquí es
donde tenemos que desarrollar la
intuición y podemos tratarlo como si
fueran números esta anotación las hace
ver como fracciones y si seguimos esta
idea podríamos cancelar esto con esto
otro esto no es algo formal pero nos
ayuda a darnos una idea de lo que ocurre
al final nos quedamos con la derivada de
esta función al cuadrado con respecto a
x lo anotamos nos quedamos con la
derivada de nuestra función original
con respecto a x que es exactamente a lo
que se refiere de hd x esto de aquí es
la función h original quizá esto le siga
pareciendo algo complicado pero en los
siguientes vídeos veremos más ejemplos y
después trataremos de analizar esto de
forma abstracta con eso terminamos y nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo